you all what's going on guys my name is
Jenna welcome to episode 12 of game
programming one more thing before I
begin yesterday's video episode 11
didn't really publish correctly like at
all I don't know what happened to
YouTube I wasn't the only problem I mean
obviously I was not the problem let me
just try that again I wasn't the only I
guess content creator who actually
experienced issues it was like site-wide
people's videos didn't actually publish
the home page they did publish some
other words they were live on the
channel page and they were live in the
actual um I'm going to show you guys
actually so open YouTube real quick look
over here if you go to like I don't know
like let's just say harsh right that
they wouldn't be on the front page but
they would be on the actual like over
here so if you do click on my name here
and you are you checked it out you know
you'd say um-hmm you'd see my video but
you wouldn't see it on your actual
subscriptions page so you might have
missed it if you did it did actually
come out yesterday last night as usual
and just go to my channel check it out
it would be like right there on my
channel so just keep that in mind okay
and in the future if you see like a
video that doesn't come out that that's
actually why I asked you guys to follow
me on Twitter and Facebook and care
something something like like this
happens I always link it so in other
words um a lot of people actually see it
before it even publishes to any anything
on YouTube so a lot of people actually
catch the video while still processing
and sort of catch it before YouTube
fully publishes it so if you do follow
me on Twitter and Facebook you will
never miss a video that I put out sorry
that's just a pro tip for you okay
anyway back to this so yesterday we took
a look at actually I'm managing you know
getting off the screen now there is a
problem I'm going to quickly reset this
back and I'm going to deal with another
part of array index out of bounds and
that is the opposite of this so if I
just put it like this you guys and say
probably we'll make it like 50/50 now
even like 150 or something
guys driving slowly numbers timer this
time from a talk we managed this problem
when it gets off the screen and the
problem is if we actually reverse this
so I'm just gonna come in here and
change this to minus minus one more
thing actually a lot of people ask if
they should take this code down
including why time you don't have to ok
I'm literally showing this to
demonstrate to you how it works I will I
will be getting rid of this code I'll be
getting rid of these two variables and I
will be replacing these back with X&Y in
the for loop okay I'm just literally
just taking the time to actually explain
to you guys how this works because that
is a point of the series to take it nice
and slow and to teach you guys how and
why everything works so if I reverse it
like I did here right so what's going to
happen is this variable starts at 150
respectively but it's gonna get smaller
so we're going to go the opposite way
what's going to happen is up we've hit
it there we go crash now why is there a
crash because again it's still out of
bounds
remember we range if I go variables we
range from 0 to 9 to 0 to 50,000 399
I've tried to access a negative index
that does not exist that is still out of
bounds ok if it's over if it's too much
or if it's too little so in other words
negative then that causes an array index
out of bounds exception how do we deal
with that pretty simple okay what we've
got here is if Y time is greater than or
equal to height we break it's pretty
simple to fix this all we need to do is
say that if Y time is actually less than
0 or if it's greater than height let's
break okay simple as that
we've done greater than the height so in
other words that's when it gets out of
the screen going down when it gets out
of screen going up it's going to be less
than 0 and we can say that if it is less
than 0
let's break and we we need to the exact
same thing for X I assume you guys know
how long how this works in terms of um
the actual if statement obviously we've
got if X time is less than 0 and then
this this little double pipe thing arm
means or so in other words if this
statement is true or this statement is
true do this so break okay and I think I
explained break last time
but now we can we can run this and
you'll see that um we're fine we don't
crash so that's the basis that that's
the basics of them or the basis of of
how this is going to work and if we just
get rid of Y you can see that the X
works as well so here we are traveling
nicely and then we're gone so um that is
how that works
oh my god now is probably next time so
tomorrow we'll take a look at what are
we gonna do next
no clue um hmm probably next time hmm
what's next I've no idea what's next ah
we'll probably move on to beginning um
oh whoa no
before we begin building tiles will
actually um probably add like a um like
a n FPS counter as well as a timer to
actually control this and make sure that
update only happens 60 times a second
okay so a lot of time a tomorrow um but
until then guys make sure to LIKE the
video if you did like the video and I
will see you guys a see you guys
tomorrow bye
[Music]
you